Matt is a senior with a 4.0 grade point
average I'm sure that's a mistake
his declared major is philosophy and
religion his minor is German he intends
to pursue a future career as either a
pastor or a missionary at Hillsdale he
volunteers for a few good men serves as
a resident advisor in the Simpson
dormitory participates in these students
for life club and belongs to both the
Phi Sigma Tau philosophy honorary in the
Delta Phi Alpha German honorary Matthew
assists with a local Scout troop
and besides his Compact ivities he
recently led a mission trip to the
Ukraine he also belonged to the Boy
Scouts reaching the rank of Eagle Scout
and he worked at the Henson Scout
Reservation Matt is the oldest of three
children his sister Meghan is a college
sophomore his brother Tim is a high
school senior the family lives in Bear
Delaware his father is an information
technology consultant while his mother
is a part-time teacher welcome class of
2018 I'm honored and delighted to speak
to you and to your families today you
don't know me yet although if you live
in Simpson tonight you surely will but
in one sense I already know you
odds are I know what you're thinking and
what you're excited about and even what
you're nervous about that's because
there's three years ago I was sitting
right over there in between my parents
and I was trembling at the thought of
what I got myself into you see I had
heard the rumors of how hard this place
is and it absolutely terrified me and I
suspect that many of you have heard the
rumors too you're probably a tangled
mixture of nerves and anticipation right
now just like I was that's why I would
like to do my best to reassure you and
excite you about the task you are about
to undertake to do that I would like to
start by sharing the story of how I came
to Hillsdale College it begins on a
prospective student day in December 2010
at the Kirby Center in Washington DC at
the end of our tour my dad and I somehow
wound up in the front row to his speech
presented by dr. Arnn in that speech he
told us about Aristotle and explained
Aristotle's concept of nature the idea
that things have
specific ends or purposes to them so for
example he explained that the end of a
horse is to run well and majestically
what he said next though I'll never
forget he paused for a moment and looked
intently at me it's kind of intimidating
and then he looked back at his audience
and he pointed to me he said Aristotle
would look at this boy and he would say
he is not a horse his end is different
it is not simply to run and at that
moment I knew exactly where I had to go
to college
Hillsdale of course but at the same time
you can see the sweet irony of this fact
I chose Hillsdale simply because its
president told me I'm not a horse irony
aside though I've thought about that
moment several times since then as I sat
down to compose this speech I began to
draw more connections between that
moment and the meaning of life at
Hillsdale College you see the fact that
you and I are not horses ought to send a
shock wave right to the core of how we
go about our education we can do more
than work eat and sleep we can do more
than flee pain and pursue pleasure we
can think we can speak we can wonder
imagine and rejoice that is a tremendous
thing a gift and yet it is an almost
forgotten thing in the world today it is
not however a forgotten thing at
Hillsdale College that's why we are here
we long to ask ourselves the deepest
questions to look in the mirror and say
what is man to look at the world and
delight in the beauty of all creation
and ponder the meaning of it all we want
to know what it means to be able to
think to learn to wonder so we come to
this place because it is full of
professors and students who earnestly
pursue the answers to these questions we
come to vote to devote ourselves to this
end together now when I came to
Hillsdale dome I thought I was hot stuff
and I thought I knew what it meant to
take this goal seriously I was one of
those homeschooled kids who worked most
of the time and then spent the rest of
his time worrying about his work as I
thought about it though I've come to
suspect that Hillsdale students in
general tend to fall prey to this idea
that college is simply all about working
hard whether it's in athletics academics
or anywhere and beteen between we've
come to take this seriously
but take it from someone who used to
study long into Friday and Saturday
nights with his dorm room shut tight
that's not what Hillsdale College is all
about
if you treat college like it's only
about working hard building a good
resume tool and a stellar job or even
and here's the tricky one making
yourself the smartest person in the room
then you're actually treating yourself
like a horse good for nothing except
hard grueling work think about our motto
strength rejoices in the challenge
the second word there is key rejoices we
like to look at words like strength and
challenge because these are mighty words
words that seeing of great feats and
accomplishments but they are not the
most important words our motto does not
say strength overcomes the challenge or
strength rises above the challenge even
horses can do these things rather our
motto says strength rejoices in the
challenge during your four years here
you will be totally submerged in the
challenge there is great danger in that
the danger though is not the possibility
that you might - your GPA on the rocks
it's not even that you might drown in a
bottomless sea of tests papers and
reading assignments the danger is that
you could miss the point that you will
excel at all you put your hands to ace
your classes build that glittering
resume become the best athlete on the
field and land a stellar job and yet
settle for a joyless education which is
no education at all but if you let them
the things you study here well as CS
Lewis said prick you with stabs of joy
they will point to something outside
yourself something worth desiring worth
pursuing something you can't just know
about something you have to taste for
yourself and live out but you must see
through your work and look for the
deeper meaning in the books and in the
learning you must live and learn as
though there is something real in this
work and this world before us because
there is and so I hope that you will
soon find a much found of this much
sooner than I ever found that some of
the sweetest moments at Hillsdale
College are the nights when the cell
phones goes silent the laptops are shut
tight and the conversation amongst
friends soars far and wide into the
night it is in those moments that the
notes from the classroom and the
from the books come alive in our life
together and it is then that you will
get a taste of joy of the realness and
meaning of your education in fact it is
only then that your education will truly
begin so as I welcome you to Hillsdale
College I'm really beckoning you to join
us in this fellowship in this
partnership and in this pursuit for joy
I look forward to meeting many of you
and working by your sides and I hope joy
will find you while you are here for the
next four years as you begin though just
do me a favor and remember one thing
you're not a horse